in 2014
us put a hold on gain and function
research in response to a number of
laboratory biosecurity incidents
including anthrax smallpox and influenza
in december 2017
nih lifted this ban
because quote gain of functional
research is important in helping us
identify understand and develop
strategies and effective countermeasures
against rapidly evolving pathogens that
pose a threat to public health
all difficult questions have arguments
on both sides
can you argue the pros and cons of
getting a function research with viruses
i can
and first let me say this term gain of
function
is causing such confusion that i need to
take a minute and just sort of talk
about what the common scientific
use of that term is
and where it is very different when
we're talking about the current
oversight of potentially dangerous human
pathogens
as you know in science we're doing gain
of function experiments all the time
we support a lot of cancer immunotherapy
at nih
right here in our clinical center there
are trials going on where people's
immune cells are taken out of their body
treated with a genetic therapy that revs
up their ability to discover the cancer
that that patient currently has maybe
even at stage four and then give them
back
as those little ninja warriors
go after the cancer and it sometimes
works dramatically that's a gain of
function you gave that patient a gain in
their immune function that may have
saved their life so got to be careful
not to say oh gain of function is bad
most of what we do
in science that's good involves quite a
bit of the hat
and we are all living with gains of
function every day i have a gain of
function because i'm wearing these
eyeglasses otherwise i would not be
seeing you as clearly i'm happy for that
gain of function
so
that's where a lot of confusion has
happened the kind of gain of function
which is now subject to very rigorous
and very carefully defined oversight
is when you are working with an
established human pathogen that is known
to be potentially causing a pandemic
and you are enhancing or potentially
enhancing its transmissibility or its
virulence
we call that eppp
enhanced potential pandemic pathogen
that requires
this very stringent oversight worked out
over three years
by the national uh science advisory
board on biosecurity
that needs to be looked at by a panel
that goes well beyond nih to decide are
the benefits worth the risks in that
situation
most of the time
it's not worth the risk only three times
in the last three or four years
i have experiments been given permission
to go forward they were all an influenza
so i will argue that if you're worried
about the next pandemic
the more you know about the coming enemy
the better chance you have to recognize
when trouble is starting
and so if you can do it safely
studying influenza
or coronaviruses like sars mers and
sarsko v2
would be a good thing to be able to know
about but you have to be able to do it
safely because we all know
lab accidents can happen and i mean look
at sars where there have been lab
accidents and people have gotten sick as
a result
we don't want to take that chance unless
there's a compelling scientific reason
that's why we have this very stringent
oversight
the experiments being done at the wuhan
institute of virology
as a sub-award to our grant to eco
health
in new york did not meet that standard
of requiring that kind of stringent
oversight i want to be really clear
about that because there's been so much
thrown around about it
was it gain a function well in the
standard use of that term that you would
use in science in general you might say
it was but in this use of that term that
applies to this very
specific
example of a potential pandemic pathogen
absolutely not
so nothing went on there
that should not have happened based upon
the oversight there was an instance
where the grantee institution failed to
notify us about the result of an
experiment that they were supposed to
tell us where they
mixed and matched
some viral genomes and got a somewhat
larger viral load as a result but it was
not epp it was not
getting into that zone that would have
required this higher level of scrutiny
it was all bat viruses these were not
human pathogens
so they didn't cross a threshold within
that gray area that makes for an eppp
they did not and anybody who's willing
to take the time to look at what epp
means and what those experiments were
would have to agree with what i just
said what is the biggest reason it
didn't cross that threshold is it
because it wasn't jumping to humans
is it because it did not have a
sufficient increase in virulence and
transmissibility what's your sense
epp only applies
to agents that are known human pathogens
of potent of pandemic potential
these were all bat viruses derived in
the wild
not shown to be infectious to humans
just looking at what happened if you
took four different bat viruses and you
tried moving the spike protein gene from
one into one of the others to see
whether it would bind better to the ace2
receptor that doesn't get across that
threshold and let me also say for those
who are
trying to connect the dots here which is
the most troubling part of this and say
well this is how sars cov2 got started
that is absolutely demonstrably false uh
these bat viruses that were being
studied had only about 80 percent
similarity in their genomes to tsar's
cov2 they were like decades away in
evolutionary terms
and it is really irresponsible for
people to claim otherwise
you